despite the primetime opinion programing on
Fox news continuing could be 99.9% aggressively
in favor of the president.
There are more and more sort of little [inaudible]
cracks in the narrative at Fox news and I
have another one for you today.
This is from Fox news legal analyst Andrew
Nepal Caetano who's a former judge Nepal Caetano
suggested some things that we've all actually
been saying for a long time who were on the
side of logic reason and just observing what
is out there in the world, which is that Donald
Trump may be unfit to serve as president.
This is a side from his policy views.
This is aside from the corruption and the
bribery, bribery and everything else.
This is not something you typically hear on
Fox news, which makes it more important.
It makes it more notable that that is the
venue in which it is being said.
So we'll take a look at it.
This is from a judge Andrew Nepal [inaudible]
program, Liberty file on Fox nation.
I mean, it's all terrible, right?
These can't be the people we are looking to
for solutions in society.
But when they point out the obvious, it actually
does say a little something.
Let's take a look at what he had to say.
And nearly three years in office president
Donald Trump has spent federal dollars not
authorized by Congress, separated families
and incarcerated children at the Texas Mexico
border in defiance of a federal court order,
pulled 1000 American troops out of Syria,
ignoring a commitment to allies and facilitating
war against civilians there, and sent 2000
American troops to Saudi Arabia without a
congressional authorization or declaration
of war.
He has also criminally obstructed a department
of justice investigation of himself, but escaped
prosecution because of the intercession of
an attorney general more loyal to him than
to the constitution, the constitution.
At the outset of his presidency, Trump took
the presidential oath of office promising
that he would faithfully execute his obligation
to preserve, protect, and defend the constitution.
So here, judge Andrew Nepal Tano is laying
out some of the actions of Donald Trump that
are problematic.
But then later in his monologue, he gets to
the bigger picture of Donald Trump's fitness
for office.
And he's pointing out, you know, initially
he points out all the ways in which Donald
Trump is flouting the constitution.
He's ignoring the rule of law.
But then judge Andrew Nepal Caetano gets to
this bigger picture issue of Trump's fitness.
President Trump has become known for forceful
and often tasteless banter.
He publicly calls people crude names, uses
foul language and send sends dog whistles
of lawless behavior.
Too much many of his supporters.
All of that is a question of free speech,
personal taste and political risk.
But threats to ignore parts of the constitution
are not matters of speech, taste or risk.
They reveal character traits that question
the president's fitness for office.
Now he's not saying that it's because of possible
cognitive decline or early dementia.
He's not saying it's because of possible,
uh, amphetamine abuse, which we've been talking
about.
But he is at least talking about fitness,
which again, you don't hear this on Fox news
in typical circumstances.
Now, as a result of that, Andrew Nepal, the
town may well end up like Shep Smith, meaning
no longer working at Fox news, but at the
same time let's not underestimate the possibility
of this as a strategy.
These little sporadically planted counterpoints
to Donald Trump, including on their Fox nation
shows which are I think Fox nation is only
online or maybe buried somewhere on some cable
systems.
These little counterpoints to Trump could
be a setup to pivot away from Trump as more
and more supporters jump ship.
If that happens.
We're just in unprecedented territory.
We have no idea.
Ultimately what might happen, the circumstances
today couldn't be more different in Donald
Trump's fight for reelection than they were.
For example, when George W. Bush was trying
to get reelected in 2004 back in 2004 there
was no impeachment inquiry against George
W. Bush.
Fox news was totally behind him.
The Republican establishment was totally behind
him.
In 2019 into 2020 Donald Trump is facing an
impeachment inquiry.
There are more Republicans than we typically
see in a Republican administration who are
disgusted with what Trump is doing.
You are seeing cracks in the armor of the
right wing establishment media narrative,
so it is unprecedented territory.
Andrew Nepal.
Antonio could simply be ignored because Fox
figures, nobody's really watching this guy
on Fox nation.
He could be there specifically to do these
things, to give Fox cover to say we have ideological
balance or he could be there to lay the groundwork
in case Fox decides they go a different direction
when it comes to their support of Trump in
2020 although I don't find it particularly
likely